lots of people have a positive
experience of online dating one of the
criticisms of my book is that I I show
case a lot of negative content in terms
of opening cyber but there's a good
reason for that we have an army of
marketeers over here telling us it's all
good
I want to position myself over here
saying well it's not so good and
hopefully then we can meet in the center
and have a balanced debate so online
dating what could go wrong well like all
things in life it comes with risk
so the nca which is a National Crime
Agency in the UK police force recently
issued a report to say that there has
been a six-fold increase in sexual
assaults associated with online dating
and what was really disturbing about
that report is that 71% of these
assaults took place on the first date
and either in the home of the victim or
the offender so the question is well why
is that happening
so if you look more closely at the
research as a forensic cyber
psychologist the thing that really
disturbed me is that the offender's
reported didn't have the typical profile
of a sex offender in that they didn't
have previous convictions and they
didn't have a criminal record a large
number of them did not have a typical
profile so what does this mean does it
mean that sex offenders are now moving
online to online dating forums to find
victims more easily or does it mean that
something else is happening in the
dating world
and it's ending up with this
catastrophic outcome so let's think
about us from a cyber psychology
perspective when you date online you
create this avatar this profile this
representation of self but is it really
you or is it an idealized version of
self and let's not forget the person
that you're trying to date is also
creating this profile Princess Diana
we all remember Princess Diana she said
that her marriage was a little crowded
because there were three people in it
well online dating you've got four
people in the relationship you've got to
cyber selves and you got to real world
cells so the question is do you really
know the person you're dating we talked
to kids about stranger danger I want to
talk to you guys about stranger danger
in terms of online dating as the police
say get to know the person and not the
profile so what is the science behind
why you think this stranger is suddenly
an intimate friend in cyber psychology
we talk about hyper personal interaction
which basically means that people move
towards extreme amounts of
self-disclosure online very quickly self
disclosure in the real world operates at
around forty percent according to one
study but increases to 80 percent once
you go online this is a lean medium very
few visual cues and what happens is that
as you get pieces of information you can
tend to fill in the blanks and turn this
person into something much more
aspirational your ideal partner but it's
not a reality and you don't know the
person it's a little like for we called
stranger on the train syndrome it's easy
to sit down with a total stranger and
totally disclose
but there are consequences and
real-world consequences and in the
reports the police report their
researchers felt that the root of the
problem was what they classified as
misdirected expectations which means
that the chat online whatever platformer
there was text-based or chocolate
platforms had quickly escalated into
very intimate and sexualized content in
some of the cases which in turn meant
that when there was a real-world meeting
that there were misdirected expectations
to be clear sex without consent is a
crime so if anybody has been a victim of
a sexual assault associated with online
dating you must report it immediately
one of the big problems we face from a
policing perspective is the
underreporting of crime associated with
online dating it is estimated that less
than one in five of these assaults are
reported and possibly because the victim
may feel that the digital trace they
have left online somehow may have
compromised their position that is not
the case a crime is a crime is a crime
irrespective of the way that the victim
engaged with the offender